the jurgen experience
boys the crew is bad
[Applause]
companion hey it's been forever holy
[ __ ] yeah what about four years
what about the pandemic and that it's
like
we didn't do one but was hard because
like we'd have to get one that wasn't
working
right so i work all the north american
ones and you're awesome doing it that
much yeah and i'm here now and then tour
dates so it's like everyone has to be in
the last thing you're not working
together is 1917 1987.
last time boys
it was sometime in 2020 for sure no
death whistle yes right before the
pendant
i got that thing tucked away in a box
okay okay you're gonna be sorry i'm
gonna conjure a demon that's a bad idea
i'm not superstitious about many things
but that aztec death whistle after he
blew that and the whole world fell apart
everything went to [ __ ] maybe that's not
good because that was a real one that's
a real one from mexico that's a real one
oh
yeah out
brought me that back from [ __ ] mexico
that's a legitimate aztec yeah and i was
bored i was like oh we're doing this i'm
gonna go life is great
you